Traduttore: E. M.
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Applausi)
Buona sera a tutti.
Allora, il viaggio di cui vi parlo
questa sera
è un racconto che secondo me
molti di voi già conoscono.
Quelli più giovani probabilmente
lo hanno visto in una puntata dei Simpson,
dove Bart si ammala
e Homer viene ridotto a un microbo,
entra nell'organismo di Bart
e cerca di guarirlo.
Quelli che sono
diversamente giovani, come me,
potrebbero averlo visto in questo film
di fantascienza degli anni '70.
Cosa succede?
Raquel Welch viene attaccata
dagli anticorpi, in una scena famosissima,
perché si trova all'interno di
un corpo umano,
all'interno di un paziente che
ha avuto uno stroke.
Lo stroke si verifica quando
un vaso cerebrale,
fabbricato per portare sangue
al cervello,
viene chiuso da un coagulo.
Il sangue non passa più,
il cervello morirà,
il paziente probabilmente morirà.
La storia di Raquel Welch comincia
in un laboratorio segreto,
sotto il deserto del Nevada.
La storia vera, la storia che ha reso
questa fantasia una realtà,
nel ventunesimo secolo, comincia
invece a Lisbona, circa un secolo fa.
Vedete, è una città di mare,
e vedete su questo tram -
che porta all'ospedale principale
della città - c'è il nome Moniz.
Moniz era il titolare
della cattedra di neurochirurgia
verso il 1905-1910.
Ed era un chirurgo famosissimo,
era già famoso,
aveva già ricevuto il premio Nobel,
perché aveva proposto un intervento
che per i tempi
era assolutamente rivoluzionario.
E l'intervento si chiamava
lobotomia frontale.
C'era il problema dei pazzi furiosi,
cioè pazienti psichiatrici
che erano incontenibili
e che erano costretti a passare
la vita incatenati al letto,
rinchiusi a chiave in
una stanza di manicomio.
Moniz propone di danneggiare
selettivamente i lobi frontali
di questi pazienti, in modo che
diventassero quieti.
In effetti così era.
L'intervento si svolgeva così:
Moniz non lo faceva,
perché era ammalato.
Aveva un'artrite deformante che gli
impediva di lavorare,
però aveva un assistente molto bravo,
al nome Almeida Lima,che lavorava per lui.
- Allora Almeida,
facciamo quest'intervento.
- Si professore.
Qui l'osso è molto sottile.
Prendevano un oggetto acuminato,
non so, un telecomando, e zac, zac.
E il paziente di colpo
diventava tranquillo.
Capite che erano interventi per gente con
stomaci di ferro.
Non c'era l'anestesia generale,
non c'erano gli antibiotici.
Immaginate cosa succedeva se,
invece di questo intervento così semplice,
ne facevano uno complesso.
Si tagliava la cute,
si trapanava il cranio,
si toglie un tassello osseo,
si taglia la meninge,
si sposta il cervello
e poi magari non c'è niente da operare,
perché non c'era la TAC.
Non c'era la possibilità di fare
nessun tipo di esame,
per cui a quel punto, in buon ordine,
il chirurgo richiudeva,
cuciva la meninge,
metteva l'osso,
rimetteva la cute,
porgeva le scuse al paziente
che, nel frattempo,
probabilmente, era pure morto.
Immaginate le condizioni
in cui si operava.
Moniz affronta anche
questo problema, e dice,
"Ma noi faremmo un gradissimo passo avanti
se invece di operare alla cieca
operassimo sapendo cosa c'è
dentro il cranio."
Hanno appena inventato i raggi X.
Chiama il suo fido assistente:
- Almeida facciamo un radiografia
a questi pazienti.
Fanno un radiografia e quello che
si vede è questo.
Cioè, se uno fa una radiografia di una
testa, fondamentalmente vede l'osso.
Il cervello non si vede.
Allora, questo problema in radiologia
viene così affrontato: non si vede?
Utilizziamo un contrasto che possa
differenziarmi una struttura dall'altra.
E Moniz pensa, "Perché devo mettere un
contrasto dentro il cranio
e fare un buco?
Lo metto nella carotide,
e poi il flusso ematico
me lo porterà nel cranio,
e qualcosa io riuscirò a vedere"
E così facendo, chiama il fido
Almeida e dice,
- Almeida ci vuole un contrasto.
-Si professore, cosa utilizziamo?
- Ci vuole una cosa radio opaca,
un metallo ad esempio,
qualcosa che fermi i raggi,
e vediamo come nero.
- Si professore, cosa iniettiamo?
- Iniettiamo il ferro.
Il ferro non va bene, non ce la facciamo..
- Iniettiamo il piombo.
Il piombo va altrettanto poco bene.
- Il plutonio..
Il plutonio non l'hanno ancora scoperto.
(Risate)
Però avevano scoperto il radio,
e avevano scoperto anche il torio.
Velenosissimi, ma solubili in acqua.
Per cui preparano una soluzione,
e Almeida la ispira nella siringa e la
inietta nella carotide di un paziente.
La prima angiografia celebrale.
Moniz è felice.
Almeida è felice.
Il paziente: muore immediatamente.
(Risate)
Beh, non si lasciano certo
spaventare da un cadavere.
Per cui il giorno successivo,
riprovano,
e il paziente di nuovo muore.
E poi il terzo, e muore di nuovo.
E Moniz scriverà nel suo diario,
"Abbiamo fatto angiografia
a 1,2,3,4,5, malati:
sono morti tutti."
E finalmente il sesto malato non muore,
e riescono per la prima volta al mondo
a ottenere delle immagini
come quelle
che vedete qui.
E cioè,
quei vermiciattoli neri sono
i vasi cerebrali riempiti di contrasto,
sono le arterie che riempiono il cervello,
e poi il sangue defluisce nelle vene.
Non siamo ancora a vedere il cervello,
ma abbiamo un'idea di quello che succede
nella scatola cranica,
e soprattutto abbiamo generato
una mappa dei vasi.
Ora, questa tecnica viene utilizzata
per molto tempo,
viene perfezionata,
i malati non muoiono quasi mai,
e per un certo periodo, in tutto il mondo,
si fanno queste angiografie celebrali,
fino a che viene sviluppata la TAC,
che è una metodica molto meno invasiva,
e che permette di vedere tutto
schiacciando semplicemente un pulsante,
senza dover fare del male al paziente.
Per cui questa metodica rimane così,
nel limbo, poco utilizzata,
per moltissimi anni.
A questo punto, se ricordate
da dove siamo partiti,
cioè dal sommergibile atomico
che entra nei vasi,
abbiamo a bordo Raquel Welch
- forse -,
abbiamo a bordo Moniz,
che ci ha disegnato la mappa,
e introduciamo il terzo personaggio,
che è questo.
Questo è il papà felice senza occhiali.
Ho chiesto a mio figlio -perché
la foto del paziente non si può mettere -
ho detto, "Disegnami un papà felice",
e mio figlio mi dice, "Papà felice con gli
occhiali o papà felice senza occhiali?"
"Papà felice senza occhiali,
per motivi scaramantici". (Risate)
E questo è il papà felice
senza occhiali.
Allora, il papà felice senza occhiali
è felice perchè è Natale.
Questa è una storia vera.
E' Natale,
si alza dal letto
e di colpo si accascia di fronte
ai due figli e alla moglie.
Si capisce immediatamente
che è successa una cosa gravissima,
per cui viene portato di corsa
in ospedale.
In ospedale,
"Facciamo una TAC",
e la TAC sembra normale, non si vede
nulla, ma il paziente non si riprende.
Per cui,
"Facciamo una angiografia celebrale",
quella di Moniz,
e il risultato è questo:
voi vedete che questa arteria
si suppone vada ad irrorare il cervello,
ma non ci va, perché?
Perché c'è un coaugulo che la occupa,
ed il coaugulo ferma il flusso del sangue,
e il cervello nutrito da
quell'arteria morirà,
e il paziente morirà, o peggio.
Questa arteria si chiama
"arteria basilare",
e fornisce una struttura celebrale
che è il tronco encefalico.
Il tronco encefalico è una zona
in cui tutti gli impulsi
che dalla corteccia vanno all'organismo,
e dall'organismo vanno alla corteccia -
la corteccia è la sede
della nostra coscienza
e della nostra volontà -
passano di lì.
Per cui se io, o se un altro, ha
una lesione al tronco encefalico,
e vuole muovere il braccio sinistro,
non lo può muovere,
perché l'impulso non passa;
il braccio destro non lo può muovere,
le gambe non le muove,
e non parla, e non sente nulla,
e tutto quello che può
fare è muovere gli occhi,
perché i neuroni
che controllano gli occhi
sono al di sopra
di quella lesione, solitamente.
Quadro drammatico che i neurologi
chiamano "Locked in":
il paziente è chiuso
dentro il suo stesso cranio,
non può fare nient'altro
che muovere gli occhi.
Ora, noi siamo qua, siamo a dieci
centimentri da una malattia tremenda,
che condannerà questo paziente
a una vita - alla morte se va bene,
o a una vita disperata,
se va meno bene.
E non facciamo nulla.
Allora, sono quindici anni fa,
non abbiamo le armi per combattere...
Però a Torino e
in pochi altri ospedali al mondo,
soprattutto in Germania,
qualcosa proviamo a fare.
Tipicamente iniettiamo la varechina,
dei veleni che sciolgono i coaguli.
Oppure proviamo
con degli strumenti inadatti,
dei palloni, il catetere per le coronarie,
e qualche volta abbiamo successo, qualche
volta abbiamo dei risultati brillanti,
ma la maggior parte delle volte
le cose vanno male,
e il paziente muore,
nonostante le nostre manovre,
o magari per colpa delle nostre manovre.
Quadro sconfortante.
Noi per una decina d'anni combattiamo
contro questa malattia terribile,
veramente, con le unghie e con i denti,
perché non abbiamo altro.
Fino a che, per puro caso,
come molte volte succede in medicina,
viene sviluppato uno strumentino
per fare tutt'altro,
e questo strumentino si rivela
assolutamente adatto,
non a distruggere il coagulo,
ma a arpionarlo e portarlo via.
Come se uno andasse a pesca:
mette quest'amo nel coagulo e lo porta via
Lo strumentino si chiamerà
"Stentriever",
perché è a metà tra uno Stent,
che è una struttura
che serve per tenere aperti i vasi,
e un retriever,
che è una cosa
che serve per ritirare le cose.
E questo cambia le carte in tavola.
Io ne sento parlare per la prima volta
in un congresso in Francia,
a gennaio del 2011,
e a febbraio ho già provato
con il primo paziente,
e i risultati sono clamorosi.
Per cui,
se oggi arriva il papà felice
in queste condizioni,
quello che facciamo è questo:
lo mettiamo in una sala angiografica, che
ci permette di vedere dov'è il problema.
In questo caso è chiusa
la cerebrale media di sinistra.
E questo è il nostro nemico.
Lui non muoverà il braccio destro,
la gamba destra, e non parlerà più.
E noi cosa possiamo fare?
E' il nostro sommergibile nucleare,
è un catetere estremamente perfezionato
che parte dall'inguine, dalla mano,
dalla carotide, da dove vogliamo,
purchè ci sia un accesso vascolare,
e che riesce ad arrivare nel trombo.
Lo attraversiamo con
una guida metallica.
Poi, qui, non usiamo un Stentriver,
ma un tecnologia diversa,
che è un grosso tubo con un aspiratore,
che arriva, che tira, che aspira
fino a che ecco qua:
Magia! -Quasi sempre-
Riusciamo ad aprire il vaso,
se siamo arrivati abbastanza in tempo.
Se siamo arrivati in una fase
in cui il cervello non ha un danno
ancora irreversibile,
il paziente se la cava.
Il successo non è il 100%.
Ma se oggi arrivano due papà felici,
con una malattia drammatica
che li porterà alla morte o peggio,
uno di questi, almeno uno,
se ne torna a casa,
a fare esattamente quello che faceva.
E per l'altro stiamo lavorando.
E per terminare io vi farei vedere
quella che è la mia astronave,
con il mio primo pilota, il capitano
e sotto rispettivamente l'equipe,
e per Raquel Welch stiamo lavorando.
(Risate)
Grazie.
(Applausi)